还有自你半年多的粉，就是大一的时候关注你的，大一的时候就关注我了。那你今天今年才大三，我我今年大三，对你大啥事啦？我这些人，我感觉我这个人不太自信，我就是想问问你怎么才能感觉更自信一点吧。哦，那你跟我聊聊呀，你的这个不自信是因为什么原因啊？比如说是因为嗯，爸爸妈妈小的时候没有给你更多的鼓励啊，还是因为没有给你足够的信任啊，还是因为小的时候被同学欺负啦，还是因为说嗯，学习成绩一直上不去啊？到底你自己有没有分析过你的这个不自信是来自于哪里？因为什么原因导致的啊？我感觉可能家庭有一点原因吧，然后还有就是上高中的时候，可能遇到过，遇到过那种就是遇到过嗯，等下我想想怎么说啊，遇到过那种比较超社会的女生，这做就你，你是吗？对，就就就算他一个人吧，但是也没有其他多人，那你是属于从小长得比较乖巧秀气是这样的风格是吗？嗯，就是。
可一叫族微信吧，那现在在大学里面有没有担任什么班干部呀？有没有担任什么职务呀？就是我一直就是上高中之前，我感觉我都还是一个比较开朗，然后跟同学大家都比较处得来，我也敢上台讲话。这什么然后自从上了高中，然后遇到遇到这个事情以后，我感觉就是上高中那几年，我就都是整个心情很沉闷，不敢跟人就是跟跟人说话说多了，我我就感觉很压抑。有没有的时候，感觉我的朋友他们也不理解我。我跟他们说这个事情，你有没有什么特长？比如唱歌跳舞、乐器，有没有什么就是你特别感兴趣的东西啊？有的时候会弹一弹那个吉他，这种我为什么这么说呢？啊，就是很多东西，可能我们再去追究什么原因导致今天的我比较不自信追究这个事情呢，它能起到一部分的作用，但是它起不到绝对的改变的作用。风筝绝对改变的作用一定是你比如说找到一个你特别喜欢的，嗯，咱们就举个例子啊，说跳街舞或者说跳民族舞或者说干嘛。
干嘛干嘛，或者运动吧，说打跆拳道，或者是干嘛干嘛的，找到一个你特别喜欢的东西，你热爱它，你专注于它，你在做这件事情的时候，感受到快乐，就慢慢慢慢的，你自己的那种爱自己自信的那种状态会一点一点的找回来。现在如果说你已经读到大学了，读到大学某种程度来说的话，已经比很多考不上大学的人来说的话要有优势了，既然已经读到大学了，那就证明你自己的学习能力是OK的。那你一定要找到一个就是兴趣爱好，然后去融入自己的热情，去沉浸式的在这个兴趣爱好里面找到自己的那种热爱，和自己沉浸在某一个喜欢的事情的状态下的人是非常有魅力的。我不知道大家嗯有没有这种感受，我记得我有一次就是看那种。
节目就看到一个阿姨，农村的阿姨，长得也不是特别的漂亮。但是我看到她在刺绣，然后夕阳打在她的脸上，微风轻轻拂过她的头发。她在那个刺绣的那个画面，那一瞬间，因为他是那个刺绣的一个传承工艺啊，就是他这个刺绣只有他会，别人都不会，大概就是这个意思。然后我就看他一针一针的刺绣，沉浸在他自己的那个状态下，我就会觉得他特别有魅力。换句话说，他自己沉浸在那个状态下的时候，他也会觉得自己很有魅力，很美。不知道这么说，大家能不能get到我不律师那个点，就是如果说你觉得现在自己缺乏一些自信的话，就现在想想我喜欢干什么，我就一定把我的热情、我的专注融到这件事情上，然后从这件事情上找到我的那种自信，仅供参考啊。因为龙飞姐，我也不是搞心理专业的啊，也不是搞这种教育专业的，我就仅凭一个像我从农村出来的时候，我也特别没自信。刚进到城市的时候，也是怕人家嘲笑我穿衣服呀，打扮呀，也怕人家嘲笑我的口音啊，嘲笑我的爸爸妈妈是农民啊，或者嘲笑我的妈妈是保姆呀，我也有过这样的脆弱的时刻那。
那个时刻对于我来说，我用什么方法来让自己变得更强大更自信一点？那我只有一条路，就是拼了命的学习。当我的学习成绩很好，你们不懂的数学题我能解出来，你们不懂得物理的那些电路，我能画出来，你们不懂的这些化学的元素，我能去教你们的时候，我的自信就起来了。那同样的道理啊，就是推己及人，从你身上的话，你找到自己擅长的那个点，在那个点上做到投入你所有的热爱，做到极致，并且在那个点，你可以传授别人经验，教别人一些东西，慢慢慢慢就自信了。就是找到自己想做的事，然后完成它。这在就会给自己也完成一件事情，就可以让自己变得更自信，然后慢慢积累起来，是这样，是就是这样，龙律师也是这么走过来的，我感觉我现在上大学了嘛，我感觉我跟人交流这方面，我觉得是比以前高中好很多。因为遇到了同学，然后还有脱离了那个环境之后，我感觉自己还是挺快的感觉。但是我感觉我就是有点那种看事情非黑即白的嘛，我对我喜欢的。
嗯，人或者事，我就会对他也挺好的。但是，我不喜欢的人不喜欢的事，我可能就一点不想交流。这个，你是想问萌律是说这个性格对于你需不需要去改变？是不是那得得看你以后从事的工作。如果你以后从事的工作，我们打个比方说，你要进入事业单位，你要进入公务员的体系，你想要这种稳定的有保障的工作的话，那么你这个性格是需要调整的。因为说句实在话，你进呃事业单位公务员这个体系的话，你不能让别人轻易的就看出来我直播间有没有吃公家饭的，有没有在事业单位公务员体系的龙飞律师说的这个，对吧？你们有感受，就算你心里不喜欢他，你也不能让他看出来感受到你不喜欢他，所以如果将来你的工作方向，你说龙飞姐，我就想要一个稳定的工作，我想要进体制内。好，那你现在就要调整你的这个性格，你不能非黑即白，你不能说我喜欢谁，我就很明显去先，我不喜欢谁，我就甩脸色，这是不行的，行不通的啊，以后你。
会有很多工作上的障碍的，会遇到很多生活中给你穿小鞋的人的，你知道吧？你如果说你以后不想进这种公家单位，你说我以后啊，我想进那种靠自己本事吃饭，靠自己实力吃饭，靠自己技术吃饭的，或者说靠自己才华吃饭的那或许你的这种性格反而成为你的一个特色。因为从我们律师这个角度来看的话，我们觉得那种能力特别强的律师一般都瞧不起人。能力特别牛的律师的话，一般都是属于那种谁也瞧不上。就是但是他专业能力过硬，他照样能挣到钱。
就这意思，所以这个要不要调整取决于你的职业规划好吧？嗯，好的，那就太紧张了我可能太紧张了对吧？然后，龙菲姐再给你说说句实在话吧，你现在所看到的那些表面上很阳光很自信的人，其实有若干个黑夜里面，或者若干个人生阶段里面，他们曾经也不自信我。你不信的话，我在直播间给你做一个测试，我直播间有多少人是外人看你都觉得你好自信好阳光，实际上你心里是自卑的是不自信的。有的打有你就会看到，就是说不自信，自卑反而是我们人生的一种常态，没啥大不了的。大家都自卑，大家都不自信，包括菲菲姐，就骨子里有很多东西，他还是不自信的，还是自卑的。你看那么多人都一样，没啥大不了啊，我想问你一个问题啊，就是我感觉我现在就是去台上讲话了，就是非常。
你会非常紧张，我也是安然神复嘛。然后就是去台上怎样能让自己变得更自信，然后说话不要那么慌张。我建议你自己拿个条写你想要讲的关键词了1234。嗯，就像你答那个政治卷，答历史卷不都是12345个点嘛。如果你去台上讲话的话，不要怕别人觉得嗯好好笑什么的，你就拿个条，我今天要讲的点，第一个点，第二个点，第三个点，第四个点。慢慢慢慢，你就能够就是当你手上有个自己写的条的时候，因为你知道你肯定不会卡，肯定不会忘，肯定有话讲，你就会从容很多。当有一天你对吧，拿着条12345个点，你这种讲的机会多了之后，然后自己慢慢在台上能练的机会多了之后，可能到第10次到第20次的时候，你就可以不用这个条了。换句话说，就算我一直用这个条也没啥大不了，对不对？那很多领导讲话不也是都是拿稿吗？我觉得没啥丢脸的就是如果我直播间的好多姐妹，如果你很害怕公众发言，比如说你表姐结婚了啊，让你上去说两句，比如说你什么爸爸生日了，什么？爷爷生日了，让你上去说两句可以？不行的话就在手机备忘录录上。
写三个关键词，我要讲这三个点，这也是可以的，没啥大不了啊，你看就像刚才那个姐妹啊，我我跟你讲，我直播间现在2.6万人，龙飞律师，我毫不夸张的告诉你，最起码有呃23000人都是社恐对吧？我直播间2.6万人，有23000人都是属于那种怕上台演讲的，怕上台去去就公众表达的。因为我以前看过一个报道，就是说美国某一个著名的心理学家做过一个测试，这个测试就是说问人最害怕的东西是什么，当然最害怕的东西排在第一位的是死亡，这个大家都怕死啊，这很正常，排在第二位的你们猜是什么？排在第二位的就是公众表达，公众演讲，这个全世界都一样，大家都害怕这个东西，只不过可能老外有很多他特别刻意的去啊，愿意训练小孩子公众演讲的这个能力啊，可能比我们要要要孩子们的那种演讲能力比我们要强一点。这是客观的说啊，不是龙飞是崇洋媚外，就是客观的来说，同龄的孩子的话，可能老外他注重这个啊，比如说呃舅舅结婚了，外甥上去演讲一下，我经常在网上也刷到这样的视频，我就觉得特别呃，特别好，以后我们。
孩子，我也希望他。比如说，他哥哥结婚啊，就是什么表哥结婚啊，堂哥结婚了，我就让他上去发表一下演讲，让他出去讲讲话什么的，给大家逗个趣儿啊什么的。